the atmosphere surrounds us on the
earth's surface the envelope of gases
pulled down by earth's gravity here we
are warm and can breathe comfortably but
if we were to leave the surface behind
steadily ascending through the
atmosphere that won't be true for long
for the first few hundred meters above
the surface you are still in the
boundary layer where friction with the
ground influences how air moves and
behaves above this friction has no
effect and you enter the clouds first of
all fluffy cumulus and flat stratus
clouds basically high fog somewhere
between the two are cumulonimbus clouds
thunderstorm clouds with flat bottoms
but fluffy and towering above different
clouds form under different conditions
depending on the pressure humidity and
temperature distinct cloud types can
form as we rise up further the air
pressure continues to drop as does the
temperature the air pressure drops as
there is less gas overhead pressing down
on you while the temperature decreases
as the atmosphere is heated from below
by the warmth of the earth's surface
depending on the conditions different
clouds can form around this height
altocumulus and limbo stratus clouds
higher up we start to find wispy cirrus
clouds or mare's tails the vast
cumulonimbus clouds continue to stretch
up even higher above before abruptly
stopping as if running into an invisible
wall the clouds stopped and spread out
as we rose the pressure continued to
fall but looking at the temperature it
was steadily falling as we climbed away
from the surface but now remains static
and actually starts to increase as we
climb higher we've crossed the first
true boundary in the atmosphere below
was the troposphere where we are now in
the stratosphere a distinctly different
layer here temperature increases as you
get higher though it's still extremely
cold and the air pressure less than a
quarter what it was at the surface no
human can survive here for more than a
few minutes without asphyxiating or
freezing commercial jets fly here in the
lower stratosphere though as there is a
near total lack of turbulence in the
troposphere there's lots of vertical
mixing and vertical motion of air while
here in the stratosphere there is none
of that this is because the stratosphere
gets warmer with altitude while the rest
of the atmosphere is heated from below
by the earth's surface the stratosphere
has a special extra ingredient ozone
ozone can be split apart by sunlight in
a process called photolysis and when
this happens it causes the air around it
to heat up the ozone layer is right in
the middle of the stratosphere and so
the stratosphere has this unique
property of getting warmer with altitude
continuing upwards though you eventually
reach the top of the stratosphere here
the temperature is around freezing but
now starts to decrease with altitude
again and we enter the next layer of the
atmosphere the mesosphere the
atmospheric pressure here is just a
tenth of a percent of what it is at the
surface and yet we're still nowhere near
the top of the atmosphere in the
mesosphere we find the highest and least
understood of all clouds noctilucent
clouds in fact the mesosphere is barely
studied at all some scientists actually
call it the ignorosphere and we know
very little about it as we climb to the
top of it with atmospheric pressure just
a millionth what it is at the surface we
reach the coldest point in the whole
atmosphere temperatures here can reach
negative 100 degrees celsius or negative
150 fahrenheit continuing upwards just
above we cross the carmen line the most
commonly used start of space 100
kilometers above the earth's surface
there's nothing particularly special
that happens here it's just a nice round
number and it has a technical
significance for aeronautics below this
height you can fly a plane without being
in orbit around the earth well above it
you must be in orbit below the carbon
line you do aeronautics above it you do
astronautics above the mesosphere there
are still plenty of molecules of gas so
we classify this as the next layer of
the atmosphere called the thermosphere
charged particles from the sun guided by
the earth's magnetic field towards the
poles collide with gas in the
thermosphere and cause oxygen and
nitrogen molecules to fluoresce we see
this glow as the aurora borealis and
australis the temperature again rises as
we get higher but this time not because
of ozone here high energy radiation from
the sun is absorbed by molecules of gas
and as there are so few of them now
these excitations by radiation hugely
raise the temperature of the gas and as
the thermostat is heated now from above
by the sun this means the effect is
greater at the top if you were to step
outside of your spaceship here though it
wouldn't feel warm temperature ceases to
be physically meaningful other than the
average kinetic energy of the molecules
when there are so few molecules around
you the thermosphere extends from around
80 kilometers to around 600 kilometers
above the surface that means that the
international space station orbits the
earth in the atmosphere midway up the
thermosphere this means that it's
buffeted by atmospheric tides
planet-sized waves similar to ocean
tides caused by the day side of the
earth being warmer than the night side
friction with the air molecules means
that the iss like other satellites must
periodically boost its orbit or it would
fall to earth the atmosphere doesn't
have a definite end the density of air
exponentially decreases with altitude
and so there are a few different places
where we could say the top is we've
already passed one the carmen line
another is the top of the thermosphere
this is the point roughly 600 kilometers
above the surface though it varies a lot
where molecules of hydrogen and carbon
dioxide are attracted to the earth by
its gravity but there are too few of
them to behave like a gas anymore if
that still sounds like it should be part
of the atmosphere then you need to
include one more layer the exosphere
this is the final most tenuous part of
the atmosphere extending from the top of
the thermosphere to at least 10 000
kilometers above the surface and
sometimes as far as 600 000 kilometers
that would mean that the moon
occasionally passes through this most
tenuous part of the atmosphere that
trails behind the earth called the
geocorona at the top of the exosphere
the pressure that the sun's light exerts
on hydrogen atoms is greater than the
earth's gravitational pull on them and
so the earth loses its grip on those
last few molecules of air
we've now reached the definite end
of the atmosphere
if you enjoyed this video and would like
to have it represented in your dorm your
classroom office den then 18 by 24 inch
posters are available at the link below
in the description for just 12 each if
you choose to buy a poster then not only
are you getting a high quality guide to
your friendly neighborhood atmosphere
you're also directly supporting this
channel thank you for watching the video
pop it a like if you enjoyed it and
subscribe for more atmospheric content
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you